[Música]
el pasado mes de mayo de 2023 la
economía norteamericana volvió a estar
en la cuerda floja a punto de alcanzarse
el techo de la deuda y con un acuerdo
entre la casa blanca y el congreso que
se demoró más de la cuenta el Gobierno
Federal estuvo muy cerca del default os
hablamos de ello con todo detalle en
nuestro canal hermano en visual economic
las consecuencias Podrían haber sido
catastróficas 11 de mayo de 2023 dice
que el impago de Estados Unidos
desencadenaría una recesión económica
mundial sin embargo finalmente la sangre
no llegó al río el 27 de mayo el
presidente biden anunció un acuerdo con
el bloque republicano del congreso para
ampliar el límite de endeudamiento del
Gobierno Federal entonces
todo arreglado pueden los Estados Unidos
volver a estar tranquilos el peligro ya
se ha terminado pues no lo siento pero
no
[Música]
tal y como podéis ver con ampliación del
techo de la deuda o sin ella Estados
Unidos sigue siendo uno de los países
con mayor relación pib deuda de todo el
mundo y no sólo eso la economía
norteamericana se enfrentará en las
próximas décadas a un riesgo mucho mayor
y por eso en visualpolitik nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas puede El
Tío Sam llegar a incumplir sus deudas
Cuántas veces ha ocurrido esto en el
pasado todo se arregla ampliando el
techo de deuda como de sólida son las
costuras Fiscales del gobierno de los
Estados Unidos de América Pues bien en
este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas arranquemos
Aunque antes de ir con eso fijaos en
esta gráfica sabíais Que prácticamente
nueve de cada 10 suscriptores de
visualpolitik todavía no estáis
suscritos a visual economic visual
economic es nuestro canal hermano en el
tratamos temas top de la economía y
sabéis que
que estamos seguros de que os va a
gustar en visual económico hablamos de
temas tan interesantes como los
constantes bloqueos de Francia al
desarrollo económico de Europa o como
países como Israel o Taiwán han logrado
convertirse en superpotencias
tecnológicas Y por supuesto también
abordamos muchos de los grandes debates
económicos del momento Así que si
todavía no estás suscrito No esperes más
te dejamos el link en la descripción
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos amigas si bien todos
reconocemos que la economía
norteamericana es todo un Coloso de vez
en cuando algunos episodios como la
crisis del 2008 polas constantes
amenazas de que el gobierno se quede sin
dinero generan muchas dudas la última
crisis del techo de la deuda y el
posible cataclismo que podría haber
supuesto el default de una economía cuya
moneda es con mucha diferencia la
principal reserva de valor de todo el
mundo es un buen ejemplo sin embargo
esperad un momento porque lo cierto es
que todo este tema de la deuda los
descuadres presupuestarios e incluso los
de Falls no son algo precisamente nuevo
ya en su discurso de despedida el
mismísimo George Washington dedicó buena
parte de sus palabras para alertar a sus
Sucesores del riesgo que un descuadre
financiero podría suponer fijaos en
estas palabras del 19 de septiembre de
1796 El Crédito Público es una fuente
muy importante de fuerza y seguridad un
método para preservarlo consiste en
utilizarlo con la mayor moderación
posible no solo evitando ocasiones de
gasto sino realizando vigorosos
esfuerzos en tiempos de paz para saldar
las deudas que Las Guerras inevitables
puedan haber ocasionado no arrojando sin
generosidad sobre la posterioridad la
carga que nosotros mismos deberíamos
soportar desde entonces y sin importar
su signo político prácticamente todos
los presidentes han dicho preocuparse
por el enorme riesgo que supone una
creciente deuda públicas
y sin embargo pese a todas estas Buenas
palabras Lo cierto es que la deuda ha
seguido creciendo más y más sin freno
desde 1940 el techo de la deuda se ha
ampliado unas 90 veces es decir algo más
de una vez por año que se dice pronto
algo que pone sobre la mesa la primera
conclusión el techo de la deuda en la
práctica no sirve para nada ni siquiera
ha conseguido evitar que presidente tras
presidente todos eche en mano de la
inagotable tarjeta de crédito del
Gobierno Federal La pregunta es por qué
demonios todos los presidentes de
Estados Unidos parecen enganchados a la
deuda Hacia dónde se dirige el país ha
llegado el momento del ajuste fiscal
pues queridos amigos amigas de
visualpolitik ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
vamos con ello
[Música]
De hecho sí control no
como ya os contamos en nuestro canal
hermano en visual economic el ahora
conocido como techo de la deuda fue un
mecanismo de control que entró en vigor
en el año
1917 hasta ese momento cualquier
préstamo que tomara el tesoro tenía que
ser explícitamente autorizado por el
congreso para hacer este procedimiento
mucho más sencillo y al mismo tiempo
seguir controlando al Gobierno Federal
los políticos norteamericanos se sacaron
de la manga esta herramienta un límite
claro y conocido al endeudamiento que el
Gobierno Federal puede asumir es decir
una especie de doble control por un lado
el congreso aprueba los presupuestos
Pero por otro impide que el Gobierno
Federal se endeude más de la cuenta con
lo que se supone que a la hora de
preparar el presupuesto se tendría que
tener este límite muy en cuenta sin
embargo hecha la ley hecha la trampa año
tras año la casa blanca de turno se las
fue arreglando para incrementar cada vez
más el techo de la deuda al final lo que
nació como
un límite se convirtió en poco más que
una broma pesada fijaos
tal y como podéis ver el techo de 1940
fijado en unos 49 mil millones de
dólares hoy no es más que un pequeño
punto en un gráfico que refleja de forma
muy visual el voraz apetito del gobierno
norteamericano para finales de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial el techo se había
quintoplicado Y a partir de los años 80
este límite se duplicó prácticamente
cada década
[Música]
Claro que un momento porque esto tiene
algo de trampa Es verdad que la deuda
del Gobierno Federal ha crecido como un
cohete sin embargo si nos fijamos en la
relación deuda sobre pib no ha ocurrido
lo mismo o al menos no lo hizo durante
décadas de hecho en los años 80 la deuda
Federal llegó a ser tan baja como un
31,7%. El problema del techo de la deuda
es que a la hora de la verdad no sirve
para nada excepto para generar tensión
si los presupuestos son deficitarios y
el gobierno se tiene que endeudar el
techo de la deuda ha demostrado ser un
mecanismo completamente inútil excepto
insisto para generar mucha tensión
política y por extensión también
económica por eso hacía 1970 el
representante republicano Dick jeffard
impulsó la regla gefard por la cual se
entendía que si el congreso había
aprobado un presupuesto que perforaba el
techo de la deuda automáticamente
aprobaba la ampliación de este último
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea cuando esta
regla entró en vigor el techo era de
unos 830 mil millones de dólares y
cuando fue drogada finalmente en 1995 el
techo ya estaba en los cinco billones y
medio desde entonces cada vez que la
deuda se aproxima a este límite está ya
la polémica y no pocas veces la guerra
entre la casa blanca y el congreso Eso
sí al final siempre se termina moviendo
hacia arriba 2023 ha sido un buen
ejemplo Y es que en realidad el techo de
la deuda es solo una cara de la moneda
me explico Es evidente que no habría
deuda si no hubiera un gasto excesivo O
al menos un nivel de gasto por encima de
los ingresos del propio gobierno pero
hasta dónde llega exactamente el
problema realmente tenemos motivos para
preocuparnos Hasta qué punto la Casa
Blanca es adicta a la deuda pues atentos
[Música]
una chequera fuera de control
queridos amigos de visualpolitik
seguramente la inmensa mayoría de los
que estáis viendo Este vídeo tengáis
alguna deuda pendiente la tarjeta de
crédito la hipoteca un préstamo
comercial para comprarnos un coche en
fin lo que sea y a ver esto de por sí no
es algo malo no es nada malo incluso
podría llegar a ser algo bueno podríamos
por ejemplo pedir dinero prestado para
abrir un negocio o comprar un activo que
nos pueda dar una rentabilidad y en
cualquier caso sea para lo que sea si
podemos permitirnos con nuestros
ingresos el pago de los intereses y la
devolución de la propia deuda Entonces
no habrá ningún problema lo malo es
cuando todo esto se va al garete cuando
asumimos Tal cantidad de deuda que los
números ya no salen Pues bien algo así
es lo que le ha ocurrido al Gobierno
Federal de Estados Unidos Un gobierno
que vive con un enorme cañón
presupuestario de forma permanente
prácticamente cada año que pasa los
cheques que salen de la Blanca son cada
vez más y más grandes y esto es así
Incluso en términos constantes y la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es dónde
va a parar todo este dinero y sí ya sé
lo que muchos estaréis pensando Aunque
Alberto Esto va a defensa Estados Unidos
gasta toneladas de dinero en armas y
soldados verdad pues no lo cierto es que
esa no es ni de lejos la causa principal
de hecho en dólares constantes el gasto
militar no ha crecido tanto lleva casi
20 años prácticamente estancado fijaos
[Música]
Pero entonces por qué en Estados Unidos
crece tanto el gasto público año tras
año A dónde va a parar todo ese dinero
pues lo cierto amigos es que la
situación en este caso no es muy
diferente a la de Europa la inmensa
mayor parte del incremento
presupuestario tiene una explicación que
podemos resumir en dos palabras gasto
social ahora bien un momento Durante
años más o menos a pesar de esta
evolución Lo cierto es que el gasto del
Gobierno Federal en términos de pib se
mantuvo más o menos estable es decir la
economía crecía el gobierno ingresaba
más Y entonces dirigía la inmensa mayor
parte de todos esos recursos al gasto
social incluso también reducía la
inversión en otras partidas por ejemplo
alguna vez habéis oído hablar de lo mal
que están las infraestructuras en
Estados Unidos Pues eso el problema es
que en los últimos años ese método ya no
parece suficiente Así que el gasto
público en términos de pib también se ha
disparado desde que arrancar al Siglo 21
el gasto del Gobierno Federal ha pasado
de entorno al 18% a más del 30% del pib
incluso sin contar la pandemia es muy
posible que el gasto público estuviera
hoy por encima del 24 o el 25%, pero ese
ese no es el mayor problema el mayor
problema es que ese nivel de gasto
siempre ha estado soportado por un
enorme déficit un boquete presupuestario
que en 2023 estará por encima del 5% del
pib y que está haciendo que la deuda
pública crezca como un cohete un momento
pensáis que estamos exagerando como un
cohete pues fijaos
Pero esto no ha hecho más que empezar
estos son los datos y las proyecciones
de la oficina presupuestaria del
Congreso como podéis ver se espera que
en términos de pib el peso de la deuda
Federal pase de entorno al 100% hoy a
casi el 200% en los próximos 30 años y
todo esto Pese a que la recaudación del
gobierno está prácticamente en niveles
récord amigos Hasta ahora el gobierno de
Estados Unidos ha tenido una enorme
ventaja como el dólar es la moneda de
reserva internacional la demanda de
deuda pública del Gobierno Federal es
enorme eso les ha permitido incrementar
tanto su deuda sin que se disparen los
tipos de interés algo que ha provocado
situaciones como esta 1 de agosto de
2011 Putin acusa a Estados Unidos de
vivir como un parásito de la economía
global por supuesto eso no tiene nada
que ver con la realidad pero sea como
sea la pregunta es hasta cuándo puede
durar semejante globo realmente es
sostenible este camino Pues bien
veamoslo
El peor de los augurios es posible un
default
amigos el gran boquete presupuestario
que está destrozando las finanzas
públicas del Gobierno Federal de Estados
Unidos y de muchos otros países del
mundo por cierto tiene nombres y
apellidos es la seguridad social el
progresivo envejecimiento de la
población supone un gran desafío hasta
ahora Estados Unidos ha podido evitar el
tema pero lo podrá seguir evitando
durante mucho más tiempo
en el sistema de seguridad social
norteamericano los ingresos actuales no
llegan a cubrir las pensiones
comprometidas por el gobierno sin
embargo año tras año este sistema cierra
en números positivos Gracias sobre todo
al fondo de jubilación y sobrevivientes
y al fondo de discapacidad dos fondos
que se crearon en los años 1939 y 1956
respectivamente para acumular dinero
para hacer frente a los futuros pagos de
la seguridad social Porque si en Estados
Unidos a diferencia de otros países sí
que se ha ahorrado para la jubilación a
finales de 2022 estos dos fondos tenían
activos ahorrados por valor de 2,9
billones de dólares
El problema es que se espera que estos
fondos se agoten en unos años según las
últimas proyecciones podemos contemplar
tres escenarios posibles Pues bien
Incluso en el mejor escenario que se
imagina estos fondos apenas durarían
unos 15 o 16 años en el peor podrían
agotarse en menos de una década es decir
que a partir de ese momento al gobierno
Le tocará tirar de más y más y más deuda
[Música]
y ojo porque ese es solo el primer gran
desafío que la Casa Blanca tendrá que
empezar a tomarse muy en serio a partir
de ahora es el primero pero no es el
único por otro lado la enorme deuda que
ya ha contraído El Tío Sam naturalmente
obliga a pagar intereses en 2022 por
ejemplo el Gobierno ya tuvo que
desembolsar casi
400.000 millones de dólares solo para
pagar intereses y claro con tipos al
alza todo apunta a que esta cifra
seguirá creciendo Y no solo serán los
intereses el gasto social también
continuará creciendo Y para colmo la
creciente rivalidad con China y la
experiencia en Ucrania están haciendo
que los políticos de Washington quieran
impulsar el gasto militar en otras
palabras que en el departamento del
tesoro van a tener que hacer malabares
para lidiar con tanto gasto y ojo porque
aquí un cambio de gobierno difícilmente
arreglará algo en las últimas décadas el
mayor acuerdo bipartito en Estados
Unidos ha sido que no pasa nada por
gastar cada vez más en 2023 hemos visto
como la falta de acuerdo para ampliar el
techo de la deuda estuvo a punto de
provocar un default lo que disparó todas
las alarmas se arregló con una patada
para adelante que básicamente retrasa el
problema pero este será un tema que cada
vez estará más sobre la mesa la
condición de Refugio del dólar hace que
sea casi impensable pensar en que
Estados Unidos pueda suspender pagos
salvo por un desacuerdo político
pero el propio dominio del dólar se basa
en la confianza en la economía
norteamericana y también en la salud de
las finanzas públicas del gobierno la
primera en general va bien la segunda de
mal en peor no será hoy y quizás tampoco
mañana pero tarde o temprano y mejor
antes que después en Washington tendrán
que buscar una solución durante décadas
han podido vivir con un boquete
presupuestario crónico pero este no deja
de crecer y ya se está haciendo
demasiado grande amigos la economía
norteamericana va razonablemente bien
pero los políticos de Washington no
están cumpliendo con su parte y eso hace
que a medio plazo muchos analistas no
descarten que las cosas se pongan mucho
más tensas especialmente teniendo en
cuenta que en unos años las pensiones
también tendrán que financiarse con
deuda todavía hay tiempo pero esta bomba
fiscal es sin duda otra de las grandes
amenazas a las que se enfrenta Estados
Unidos mi pago no tendría prece si
podría ser catastrófico los mercados de
crédito podrían congelarse el valor del
dólar podría desplomarse los tipos de
interés estadounidenses podrían
dispararse los efectos negativos podrían
repercutir en todo el mundo y podría
producirse una crisis financiera y una
recesión que podrían ser un eco de los
acontecimientos de 2008 o algo peor Este
ha sido nuestro último vídeo de una
serie especial sobre las amenazas a las
que se enfrenta Estados Unidos desde los
problemas del pentágono a la guerra con
el Joan pasando por Irán o Corea del
Norte os dejo el enlace a esta Playlist
en la descripción pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti crees que en
Washington se empezarán a tomar este
problema en serio qué harías tú para
solucionarlo se arreglarán las cosas por
sí solas Cómo terminará toda esta
historia como siempre puedes dejarnos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y hablamos
debate y ahora si este vídeo os ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y suscribiros a
visualpolitik y aviso al economic si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]